meanwhile another Kim and Kanye
production baby shy terms one today Kim
gave her daughters some birthday love on
Instagram calling her quote the sweetest
baby in the whole world look at them
can't even drop more baby news on last
night's watch what happens live we do is
it it's sometime soon Wow yeah you know
if it's a boy or a girl
it's a boy what well it's out there I
mean I know but you haven't confirmed it
I'm a little brother foreseen yes yeah I
mean you know it would be nice she did
play coy with et in December but less
than a month after this interview a
source confirmed Kim and Kanye were
expecting a fourth child via surrogate a
boy but get this Kim actually spilled
the beans I got drunk at our Christmas
Eve party
they told some people and I remember who
I told more admissions last night
who would you rather be stuck in an
elevator with Taylor Swift or drink
Taylor Swift kind of shocking after
their headline-making feud but now Kim
also wants to be excused from that
narrative
over it good and have you two had any
communication or you just feel like
we've all moved on no I feel like we've
done one thing Chloe isn't moving on
from her relationship with Tristan after
he was caught cheating while she was
pregnant with daughter true
they were just seen Sunday night in LA
out to dinner it's so easy and quick to
be like oh my god
love him leave hand write it's so much
harder to stay and have the whole public
think that you're an idiot Berenstain
[Music]